time for today's bar chart has draghi
slayed the specter of deflation let's
look at the evidence
when it comes to headline inflation
deflationary pressures seem to be easing
look at the top chart there this is
eurozone inflation over the last 12
months there are now been four
consecutive months of below zero
inflation in the eurozone nevertheless
consumer prices did drop
0.1 percent annually in march which is
an improvement see the white circle from
the minus point six percent
in april which
in january excuse me which matched the
biggest decline in prices in the history
of the single currency going back to
2009 the two percent target to be fair
the ecb's two percent target inflation
target is still though a long way off
and yet inflation expectations are
picking up the second chart is mario
draghi's preferred
gauge for inflation expectations it's
the five-year five-year inflation swap
rate now back in january it fell to one
point four eight percent that's the
yellow circle there that's the lowest
since at least 2004 since then the trend
as you can see has been improving and
draghi's preferred inflation gauge has
risen to 1.8 percent let's move on to
the final chart i want to show this is
germany's five-year break-even rate this
is the yield difference between nominal
and inflation index linked bonds over
the five-year period now this is another
measure of inflation expectations the
trend down from a year ago through
january the low was january when it fell
to minus
26 basis points the difference between
nominal and inflation bonds back in
january was minus 26 basis points the
lowest since
2008 and as with the other charts the
trend has improved to plus 87 basis
points or point eight seven percent near
the highest since may last year so
there's the evidence has draghi slayed
the specter of deflation from looking at
these three charts at least you'd have
to say that things are certainly looking
up for the ecb president since
those three lows in january keep looking
at this chart